oh really the reason why printing him is
because it started for the community we
started showing that he actually has
power that he wasn't just one of a
monolithic voice for the big rat people
around so there's theories that there's
infinite amounts of universe in this
alternate universe so it's very
important to me to get Hoover out
because in an alternate universe I am
him and I have to go and get him free
because he was doing positive inside of
Chicago just like I'm moving back to
Chicago and it's not just about you know
getting on stage and being an
entertainer and having a monolithic
voice that's first forced to be a
specific party you know people expect
that if you're black you have to be
Democrat I have a I've have
conversations that basically said that
welfare is the reason why a lot of black
people end up being Democrat they say
you know first of all it's it's a limit
to amount of jobs so the the father's
lose the jobs and they say we'll give
you more money for having more kids in
your home and then we got rid of the
mental health Institute's in the 80s and
the 90s and the prisoner rates just shot
up and now you have chiraq what people
call chiraq which is actually our murder
rate is going down by 20% every year
just talk to the superintendent met with
my Cossacks that's Ron ROMs uh
right-hand man so I think it's the
bravery that helps you beat this game
called life you know they tried to scare
me to not wear this hat my own friends
but this hat it gives me it gives me
power in a way you know my dad and my
mom separated so I didn't have a lot of
male energy in my home and also I'm
married to a family that um you know not
a lot of male energy going on it's
beautiful though but there's times where
you know as something about you know I
love Hillary I love everyone right but
the campaign I'm with her just didn't
make me feel as a guy that didn't get to
see my dad all the time like a guy that
could play catch with his son it was
something about when I put this
hat off and made me feel like Superman
you made a Superman that was that's my
favorite superhero and you made a
Superman cape for me also as a guy that
looks up to you looks up to Ralph Lauren
looks up to American industry guys
non-political no [ __ ] put the beep
on and however you want to do it five
seconds to lay and just goes in and gets
it done right now you gave me the heart
to go to adidas because that adidas when
I went in and 2015 we're a fourteen
billion dollar company losing two
billion dollars a year now we have a 38
billion dollar market cap it's called
the easy effect and I went to Casper we
had a meeting in Chicago and I said you
have to bring manufacturing on Shore
inch not even sure into the core is that
about the borders the core of Adidas and
Chicago is the core of Middle American
we have to make middle America strong so
I had the ball because I had enough
balls to put on this hat I mean this
Dida sting made me a billionaire and I
could have lost 200 million dollars
walking away from that deal but even
with that I knew it was more important
for me to take the chance to walk away
from that deal than a half no father's
in Chicago with no homes and when we do
have prisoner reservation for no because
it's oh it's habilitation not
rehabilitation because they didn't have
the abilities in the first place we
never had anyone to taught us we didn't
teach us raised acting we had no one to
tout us right so it's more important
than any specific deal any anything that
we bring jobs into America and that we
provide a transition with mental health
and the American education curriculum
that a Jim has worked on Larry Hoover
also has a curriculum that he's worked
on we have Montessori curriculums that
we worked on we works as a beautiful
curriculum the Waldorf establishment has
a curriculum we have meditation there's
a lot of things affecting our mental
health that makes us do crazy things
that puts us back into that trap door
called a thirteenth amendment I did say
a bottlers with the hat on because why
would you keep something around us
trap door if you build in the floor the
Constitution is the face of our of our
industry right of our cup of our country
of our company would you build a
trapdoor that if you mess up and you
accidentally something happens you fall
and you end up next to the Unabomber you
end up you got to remove all that
trapdoor out of the relationship the
four gentleman that wrote the Thirteenth
Amendment and I think the way the
universe works it's perfect we don't
have 13 floors do we you know so the
forger the four German have wrote the
13th amendment didn't look like the
people they were amending also at that
point it was illegal for blacks to read
or african-americans to read and so that
meant if you actually read the amendment
you get locked up it's her to a site
again so what I think is we don't need
synthesis we need pardons we need to
talk to people I was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder I was connected with a
neuro psychologist that works with the
athletes in the NBA and NFL and he he
looked at my brand it's equal on three
parts I'm gonna go ahead drop some bombs
for you 98 percentile IQ test
I had a 75 percentile of all human
beings but it was counting eight numbers
backwards off there is ravine so I'm
gonna work on that one
the other ones 98 percent Tesla Freud
you know so he said that I actually
wasn't bipolar I had sleep deprivation
which could cause dementia 10 to 20
years from now I wouldn't even remember
my son's name
so all this power that I get and I'm
taking my son to the Sox game and all
that I wouldn't be able to remember his
name from a misdiagnosis and what we
need is we can empower the
pharmaceuticals and and make more money
that's one thing I'm never stepped into
a situation where I didn't make people
more money so we can empower
pharmaceuticals we can empower our
industries we can empower our factories
we can bring not only adidas on Shore we
could bring Foxconn a set up a factory
in I think Minnesota 53,000 yeah
Wisconsin they had 4,000 jobs people
making fifty three thousand dollars a
year
and one of the things we got a set is
for to have the highest design the
dopest cars the most amazing I don't
really say dope I don't say negative
words and try to flip them we just say
positive lovely divine Universal words
so the fly is freshest most amazing car
and what we want to start with this I
brought up I brought a gift with me
right here this right here is the I
plain one
it's a hydrogen power airplane and this
is what our president should be flying
in look at this shirt whoa what we're
gonna have Apple yeah American and
company work on this plane with but you
know what I don't like about it's not
that I don't like what I think what I
need Saturday Night Live to improve on
or what I need the Liberals to improve
on us if he don't look good we don't
look good this is our president he has
to be the freshest the fliers the flying
planes the best factories and we have to
make our core be in power we have to
bring jobs into America because our best
export is entertainment ideas but when
we make everything in China and not in
America then we're cheating on our
country and we're putting people in
positions to have to do illegal things
to end up in a cheapest Factory ever the
the prison system I'll tell you what
that was pretty impressive you know I
hate to say this Jim do you want to say
something
I've never seen Jim Brown oppressed
before he was impressed that's true that
statement is amazing that I want that
it's great to have you guys with us and
we're gonna go and we're gonna have some
lunch that was quite something you would
said of a President Bush that he doesn't
care about black people
I need you've heard some people say that
about this president when you respond to
that what do you make of that I think we
need to care about all people and I
believe that when I went onto NBC I was
very emotional and I was programmed to
think from a victimized mentality Oh a
welfare mentality I think that with with
blacks and african-americans we really
get caught up in the idea of racism over
the idea of industry we say if people
don't have land they settle for brands
we want polo sport and Obama again we
want a brand more than we want land
because we haven't known how it feels to
actually have our own land and have
ownership of our own blocks so when you
don't have ownership then it's all about
how something looks it's about the
patina it's not about the soil is that
about the core do we focus more on just
somebody wearing something that someone
disrespect me so I got it I got to shoot
them or the idea of someone being racist
you know we talk about a police of
murders which we definitely have to
discuss and we have to bring nobility to
the to the police software sins and make
them as police officers are just like us
but this is this whole hate building
right and that's a a major thing about
racial tension and we also as black
people we have to take a responsibility
for what we're doing
we kill each other more than police
officers and that's not saying that the
police officer is not an issue because
they are in a place a position of power
but sometimes they are in placement of
law enforcement they need to be law
power it's force versus power when you
have you shouldn't have to force people
to do that so a lot of times the police
offer is sitting there they're being
forced to do this and force to do that
block and then they force somebody into
something and forcing something we have
to release the love throughout the
entire country and give opportunities a
lot of times it's just the overall lack
of reparations that we at any given
point we say oh this is races this is
racing this is race this is races so we
don't have our reparations but we have a
13 commitment we got to open up the
whole conversation so and that's a move
one of the moves that I love that
liberals try to do the liberal would try
to control a black person through the
concept of racism because they know that
we are very proud emotional people so
when I said I like Trump to like someone
that's liberal they'll say oh but these
races you think races okay control me oh
they don't stop me up an invisible wall
but you don't think you have one
question we'll go to another question
okay I answer to a question I don't
answer questions as simple Sam sound
bites you you are tasting a fine wine it
has multiple notes to it you better play
4d chess with me like it's minority or
porky prison ain't that simple it's
complex
this is the president I would like to
know what you would like to ask
President Trump to do for Chicago we're
here to talk about crime in Chicago the
thing that that the head of the police
and Mike Sachs met with me last night at
the Soho House about was we feel that
stop and frisk does not help the
relationships in the city and everyone
that knew I was coming here said asked
about stop and frisk that's that's
that's a the number one thing that we're
having this conversation about another
thing is opening up industries and we've
got to get some tax breaks too because
you know we're making a
we got a speed factory in Atlanta but
the shoes are costing us $300 so it's
costing us too much to make things so we
need some prototypes here so we can get
people back working so China can't just
beat us and Vietnam can't beat us you
got Levi's the greatest jeans company in
the world making their jeans in in
Vietnam so we're gonna need to get a few
breaks to be able to have some places in
my hometown of Chicago and a 2.7 million
to the 9 million surrounding suburbs
where we can create some factories now I
think it would be cool words for them to
be Trump factories because he's a master
of Industry he's a builder and I think
it'd be cool to have Yeezy ideation
centers which would be a mix of
Education that empowers people and gives
them modern information like sometimes
people say this kit has a tedious could
have a CD you don't have a TD school is
boring
it was bored is that as exciting as this
we have to make it more say we have to
mix curriculums you play basketball
while you're doing math you you you
learn about music while you meditate in
the morning we have to in state mental
health and art programs back into the
back into the city so those are and also
Larry Hoover is an example of a man that
was turning his life around and as soon
as he tried to turn his life around they
hit him with six life sentences so I
believe he's with you stay don't tear
down the statues Larry Hoover is a
living statue
he's a beacon for us that needs to see
his family that needs to go out and
represent when you have a block leader
on every single block they can own the
block is their own that's something I
learned from Jim Brown from a mayor I
can we need to put curriculums
for people who really came from the
streets not people who are just trying
to set us up to go into a work system or
prison system that applies to what
people are really going through which
Jim Brown has created the problem is
illegal guns illegal guns is the problem
not not not legal guns we have the right
to bear arms
that favours stop-and-frisk are you guys
gonna be discussing that yes with that
we're gonna discuss I didn't mean to put
you on I ask like that bro but it's
definitely I don't have mine yeah yeah
mr. president would you like him to
speak at one of your rallies they could
speak for me anytime he wants smart
cookie smart he gets it too guys Jim
Brown he's been doing this for a long
time there's a future presidential
candidate could very well be let's stop
worrying about the future all we really
have is today we just have to date over
and over and over again the eternal
returns a hero's journey and Trump is on
his hero's journey right now and he
might not have expected to have a crazy
[ __ ] like Kanye West run up and
uh support but best believe we are gonna
make America great now the thing is my
another thing as black people have an
issue with the word again and I believe
my feeling from that is because I'm
gonna throw I'm go all the way signal it
because time is a minute all we have is
now all we have is today so the word
again is doesn't hurt us because the
idea of racism and just a really there's
a different thing it it hurts us because
we need to focus on who we are now today
I believe so I actually brought some
hats in that have a bit of a transition
time at that Trump but you're up there a
spot a little bit I made a hat up that
says make America great just that but I
would love to see at the Super Bowl
prompt wearing the make America great
hat
Colin making where they're making
America great and showing that we can
bend a bit on this side we can benefit
on this side and we can learn how to be
malleable in the infinite universe that
we are on the loving beings that we are
that we don't have to stick to all
traditions and if we aren't aside we are
one unit we are one country we are one
moment in history in time who might have
been here before but right now we're
going to gather the greatest value that
people have on other people and we need
to start working on red
like a game again I ask you this
question you're in the Oval Office how
does it feel to be in the Oval Office oh
it is good energy in there is a good
energy it's good it's a great place Jim
how do you feel I feel good I truly feel
good I thank you to your so respected
and what Kanye is doing has been
incredible all over the world they're
talking about this and I have to tell
you I had important meetings today were
senators and with everything nobody
cared they wanted this meeting this is
the meeting is that right good right but
this is what they want well it's my
honor Jim I want to tell you I've been a
fan of yours for a long time a long time
nobody liked you
nobody likes you no athlete like you I'm
here to contribute you know that's
always been the way Jim has been a long
time and he just wanted to help and it's
something special Jennifer did you have
a question I guess just you what do you
feel about stop-and-frisk for you to
have a look at it I'm open to everything
I look I think it's a shame what's
happening in Chicago I'm in Chicago a
lot too I have nice things in Chicago
you know that right and I hate to see
what's happening there having numbers
the numbers of people being shot and
killed and it's it's not it's not for
this country so they have to do
something and I am totally opened if we
can do it a different way Kanye I'm
totally open but they have to do I mean
we all agree they have to do something
that's well maybe it's a combination of
both yeah I guess it is but I think it's
probably a combination of both and it's
also a respect issue they respect this
guy they respect this guy that's a big
thing right now they're not respecting
let's say you're mayor or let's say your
leadership in Chicago but certainly it
shouldn't be happening what's going on
there should not be happening Steve good
honestly from our standpoint this was
just set up to be a lunch to people that
I like and I guess they like me and
we're gonna have lunch we're gonna talk
but I don't want to take I don't want to
put you in that spot I love this guy
right here let me give this guy I love
this guy right here yeah yes it's really
good
and that's from the heart I didn't want
to put you in that position
that's from the heart special guy
these two are special people whether you
like it whether you don't like it
they're special people and I appreciate
it Jim Connie I appreciate it
so let's go have some lunch okay thank
you all very much
[Music]
guys
just a veneer you gonna post
[Applause]